it's a balance between like owning your
blessings and your success and the path
that you've been on and the things that
you went through to get what you have
and remembering where they came from I
think when you're living in your purpose
and you're blessed enough to feel like
what you're doing every day is something
that you're supposed to be doing you
know that's a blessing and you got to
live in that you know and all the other
things around it start to make it
complicated and but I think the success
and stuff just magnifies who you really
are I think about Legacy a lot you know
when you think about things you want to
be a part of and not just a flash in the
pan something that's going to stand you
know withstand the test of time that's
going to be around longer than you know
than on my physical body is you know
life's short
so
you think about how you want to be
remembered
who did I help who did I put on who did
I nudge in the right direction so they
can achieve their dreams you know those
are things that I think about you know a
lot for me I never had a plan B you know
once I didn't go to college and I moved
out to LA
I was like man this is it this is all I
really got there was one moment in my
life I remember right when I was going
to Jack In The Box
trying to get a job I gave my last check
of everything my savings everything I
had nothing left I was like cool this is
it and I was like if it doesn't happen
this month I'm going back home to Jersey
and I'm gonna figure it out I'm gonna
figure it out I don't even know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna figure it out but I
love food I might you know become a chef
or something like that whatever
something I could do every day and I'm
in love I love I love to eat whatever
and then I booked red tail so that was
that was a bad story whatever that was
my mom and saying it was like okay cool
this is all I got after this it's over
if it doesn't work out I'm moving back
to LA and in that moment of me saying
that and like thinking that you know I
got the job that gave me the you know
the opportunity to stay in L.A just a
little bit longer than after that it was
just like things just started to like to
to flow so that's like the mix between
how I feel about that moment of like
telling somebody a it's time to give up
and then my moment of being like hey
maybe it's my time to give up I don't
mind going to like hunt for my food I
think it's I think it's fun that
competition and I know it's one point in
time where I really hated it and then I
started to become more confident and I
guess the small successes built up your
confidence and now then you don't really
mind going to auditions anymore it's
just like once I saw opportunity and you
know there was no plan B so you have to
start to strategize a bit and start to
like you know Daydream and manifest and
think about the things you want to do or
if I if I ever get the opportunity this
is how I'll do it and I just stuck to
the plan you know and obviously plans
change and they evolve as new
opportunities and situations arise but
you know the core of what I was trying
to do kind of remained the same watching
you know Denzel and Will Smith and you
know Tom Cruise and Leonardo DiCaprio
watching these guys and the choices that
they were making and how people were
receiving them and I just always wanted
to be an example or have a career where
people looked at and been like he's
doing the right way I can meditate and
pray anywhere I could be in the airport
I could be in the shower sitting there
you know I sit down with the water
running over me and for me that's my
calm that's my moments where I'm not on
my phone I have to worry about it
ringing who's texting me I have to worry
about somebody knocking on the door Mike
I need you for this now that's my time
and I sit down there and I focus on it
and I think that helps me in business
situations it helped it helps me with
negotiations it helps me with
um building companies and and producing
producing is what connecting the dots
Connecting People connecting projects
and ideas and making them work into one
thing so that means you have to convince
or
um you have to get people individuals to
all believe and buy into one dream you
know what I'm saying and feel like it's
benefit it's beneficial for them
honestly and genuinely it's not
manipulation it's not like maliciously
trying to take advantage of anything
it's no it's imposing your will and with
the with the with the the greatest of
intent to see something through to the
finish line and that's something that
I've always kind of focused on from a
young age and I feel like it helped me
out a lot in in my industry and
personally so you know I got I got a
strong group of you know I'm saying
women you know in my life that that tell
me what's up getting in certain
situations you know they always kind of
keep me grounded and and confident in
who I am because they know me regardless
of what the media or whatever wants to
spend it into some others they know me
they know my heart they know they know
what I'm about so when it comes to like
choosing roles it's like okay is this
dope is this dope I've been legit
fortunate to have great people around me
and I kind of set the tone is I don't
need no yes men around me like I mean I
need people to tell me like it is like
we all collectively have this goal in
mind of what could be if we just stick
to the plan and be patient and strategic
and that's kind of always what it's been
focus on the things that you want to
have happen you know the thing about
meditation and being very spiritual is
trying to be in line with the universe
with vibrations with what's going on in
the outside world so it's like you know
for me learning how to send my energy
off into the world to accomplish the
things that I want to see happen so when
I step out there when I leave my home
when I step out into the world it's
already working you know what I'm saying
my energy is already out there laying
the groundwork for me just to walk in
and then when I when I get there a lot
of the work's already been done for me
because I already sat there I meditated
on it I put out I put it out on the
Universe I I impose my will on the
universe I'm a workaholic I'm obsessed
with what I do you know to the top level
I don't really have that much of a
social life because I'm always like
working and conspiring on you know how
to how to make something work how do I
put the pieces together it's something
that I really really truly care about I
think everything within moderation you
know what I'm saying so I definitely
believe that but if you didn't go
through that time in your life or you
were working hard and feeling like you
had to put those hours in the gym if you
put those hours in the studio and be
around your craft how could you have the
work ethic that you have now and have
the mind to know that I want to work a
little bit less so I can work smarter
and not as hard you know because so many
people are lazy nowadays nowadays you
have your phone we're in a culture where
nobody really works hard to have instant
success they can do a video right now
that goes viral in the next week and
they're famous and they have money and
they get money for posts and they can
survive off that so it's like I think
this we live in a society nowadays where
hard work is lost and that realization
of you know mortality and people move on
and life goes on you know and and people
might forget about you in moments of
time doesn't mean that you're not
important doesn't mean that the love or
that Bond or that relationship wasn't
there it just there's the reality of
that so that fear is something that I
think in moments pushes you to to make
your life worth it you know to make
every moment count uh to leave something
behind that you could be proud of that
other people could look to and being you
know inspired by I know me I'm learning
things for the first time that a lot of
my family hasn't had the opportunity
to be exposed to so that pressure of
knowing that
and not caring about it I think is
irresponsible so
you know yeah there's a motivation of
yeah I want these nice things or yeah I
want to be comfortable but it also comes
in it's like I can't even enjoy this
Comfort if my family's not straight like
what do I look like living here feeling
like this having these things it would
mean nothing yeah they don't have that
and are able to share these experiences
with me and then it trickles down to the
bigger picture of like you know when I
do have kids when I do have you know
grandchildren and this and that and how
do I make sure that they don't have to
burden the things that I've had to
experience growing up and starting over
and having you know just all those
things I never chase money like money
has never been my thing it's always been
like I want to like build something you
know I'm saying I want to build
something that that lasts forever how do
I become lead your man it's like okay
cool I gotta like do projects that's
constantly put me in this light or like
moving me in such a way where I'll
always be respected in a certain sense
you know I mean and I never wanted to
play stereotypical roles you know and
even the ones that I did play they stood
the test of time
how do I become Universal that that's
always been my thing is like I want to
be Universal I wanted to be
International is kind of something I've
always thought about why doesn't the
stereotype of black films or black
actors don't travel overseas something
really bothered me and I was like damn
well how do I how do I get around that
it's a fine line between being
passionate obsessed and like never
giving up on your dream
and being realistic about certain things
it's weird because you kind of almost
you almost have to be insane a little
bit to have such Blind Faith in
something that you can't see there have
been times where people give up right
before they about to get whatever they
need to get like damn you right there
you right on the door and it's always
the toughest when you're like right
there when you're about to say I'm about
to walk away but then if you would have
kept going it's a little bit longer
everything would have opened up for you
so it's like a it's a real fine line
between you know walking your path and
and saying that I'm done for me there
comes a point where you you got to be
real with yourself also look yourself in
the mirror and be like okay maybe this
isn't for me let me figure out what is
for me and then you know once you're
going down that path you rarely go down
One path and be like okay this is what
I'm gonna do and this is the end-all
be-all you go down a path and then as
you're walking you might get pushed this
way or pushed that way that might end up
being your calling you know like you try
out you know you shoot for the stars you
know but if you miss you're still up in
that space you know so like you you
gotta just you know you gotta have trust
in yourself and just and just go for it